o que plantea El Ejecutivo de Gustavo
Petro para la nueva política de drogas
parece factible llegar a la legalización
en el corto plazo
Hola cómo están pues inicialmente hubo
algunos anuncios del presidente Petro
que hacían pensar que el gobierno iba a
perseguir la legalización de la cocaína
al menos en el largo plazo pero de
manera Reciente se han hecho al
contrario
algunas afirmaciones más bien con
insistencia especialmente en estos días
por parte del ministro de Justicia que
es la cartera del bueno colombiano que
está a cargo de la política de drogas en
el sentido de que no van a hacer ningún
proceso relacionado con la legalización
de la cocaína entonces pues en principio
yo diría que el gobierno ha dicho que no
que no lo va a hacer tal vez algunas
confusiones que se dieron al principio
en términos de tantos anuncios Y
decidieron que no quieren perseguir no
solamente esa propuesta sino creo que
políticamente tal vez no están
convencidos de que deben avanzar con eso
en este momento
Y por qué la cocaína genera tanto debate
a la hora de legalizarla se podría
legalizar quizás la plantación de hoja
de Coca como una medida intermedia
Sí si el gobierno no ha sido clave en
explicar exactamente qué es lo que
persigue en términos de los de La
regulación que dice querer perseguir
pero en términos de la hoja de Coca a
pesar de que tendría que tener un
proceso de todas maneras en el marco
internacional porque los convenios
internacionales los tratados de drogas
no permiten tampoco la legalización de
la hoja de poca y por lo tanto su
comercialización
pero yo creo que el gobierno sí puede
avanzar en ese sentido por lo menos en
principio con algún tipo de pilotos a
nivel doméstico que permita afianzar su
relación con las comunidades indígenas
sobre todo pues teniendo en cuenta que
ella sobre todo tienen un consumo
ancestral de la hoja de coca y tendrían
Por esa razón pues derecho
comercializarla y no la tienen en este
momento
pero en términos específicos no lo han
dicho de esa manera Entonces yo creo que
sí es posible dentro de un proceso de
debate a nivel internacional y un
proceso de desarrollo de experiencias a
nivel doméstico pero no sabemos si el
gobierno realmente va a proceder de esa
manera
sí entre tanto la plantación de coca en
Colombia siguen aumento así como el
consumo a nivel mundial ha fracasado
realmente la política contra las drogas
como Afirma Petro y que ha supuesto para
Colombia
Pues de acuerdo con la información que
recibimos en el en el informe de
Naciones Unidas sobre los cultivos de
coca que fue publicado en hace dos días
lo que vemos es pues nuevamente un
fracaso no es el fracaso de siempre yo
no creo que sea un fracaso nuevo
realmente no ha cambiado nada en los
últimos años porque la la política de
drogas en Colombia siempre ha perseguido
la disminución de cultivo y también ha
hecho fuertemente un trabajo de
interdicción incautación etcétera para
reducir el tráfico pero en términos
específicos la reducción del cultivo
nunca
sea con excepción de los años 2002 y
2013 que llegó alrededor de 50.000
hectáreas de coca en los demás años no
ha sido posible garantizar la
sostenibilidad de esos resultados
Entonces eso da cuenta de que el fracaso
ha sido pues permanente es decir lo que
estamos viendo ahorita es en mi opinión
simplemente la clarísima ausencia de la
expresión aérea que las personas aéreas
son una actividad el gobierno de
Colombia casi uno de los únicos
gobiernos del mundo que ha utilizado la
expresión aérea por unos resultados que
de forma inmediata parece positivos
porque reducen la coca pero en el largo
plazo realmente no logran nada porque
pues tendría que hacer un proceso
sostenible y las presión definitivamente
distancia al gobierno de las familias
campesinas y por lo tanto no se logra
ningún proceso sostenible Entonces sí
estamos viendo un fracaso pero no es un
fracaso nuevo que de hecho era era de
esperar que hubiera Un aumento porque el
gobierno anterior no contaba con la
expresión solamente tenía radicación
manual y el programa de salud
alternativo no estaba avanzando como se
esperaba o como se planteó en el acuerdo
de paz Entonces no había razón para que
tuviéramos un resultado diferente